hilfe okay wir machen gar kein tipp
servus sg zuletzt willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft wir spielen heute
trip sgs mal ersten mal in der aufnahme
auf rehwild tv so ist die server und mit
dabei ist der dom
hey ihr könnt uns an die art als mann
ohne altes ehepaar wegen name changer
aber ernährt der pakt ist doch wunderbar
leute hier
das spielprinzip das funktioniert so es
ist prinzipiell wsg ist in sg maps aber
es gibt keine normalen kissen sondern es
gibt diese komischen whatever they call
it kisten diese diese türkis liter
wasser hat jo jastram namens vorn
gesehen
ich glaube dass das material aus der
unterwasser festung ohne dass ich weiß
es aber noch genau diesen relativ
ähnlichen punkten
und da passieren halt die ersten sachen
wenn man wenn man die irgendwie an
klickt er kann es passieren dass
tintenfische vom himmel fallen oder als
lava aus der kiste heraus fließt aber es
muss mit einer strafe gehabt ich habe
nie die orientierung eine neue waffe
okay es ist eine flache kiste nice für
den lieben lukas so lassen die letzten
worten die letzten worte die letzten
wörter einer giftschlange hier keine
ahnung mist jetzt habe ich mir auf die
zunge gebissen oder so sachen was diese
platte raus es ist alles an sich ist ein
cooler spielmodus den stream ich auch
ganz gerne habe ich auch schon mal und
ich er ist mein erstes mal jetzt
ich erwarte gerade ganz angenehm
eigentlich bin ich halt noch kein
premium oder sogar noch keinen gp das
war jetzt glaub ich eine riesenkiste ihr
seht ihr fallt einfach rennen blumen aus
dem himmel lidl katinka hallo ich bin
ein hippie hippie hippie hippie kiste
okay gut es hat prima oder von seiner 98
79 87
die heiße 30 leiste eigentlich rwe guckt
einfach dem boden an ok lästig
exekutieren ich danke dir lieber 987
wunderbar ich heiße inside lp glaube ich
ich weiß was bedeutet es wenn leute an
den rücken zu kehren auf den boden
schauen mich von hinten
ich hasse inspire lp nämlich von hinten
nach las ich auch schon gesehen habe
stimmt ja gut dann habe ich dann habe
ich alles richtig gemacht
dann habe ich jetzt ja ich bin jetzt ich
bin deshalb deshalb die rüstung als ob
da wird holz axt um die an kopf und ein
schwert und eisenketten hose und ketten
schuhe also eigentlich und wo bist du
gerade so
ich bin sg firma darf maximal zwei tv
ich bin bei ich denke ich bin auf sp 4t
du bist ja ich weiß deswegen ist meine
art vorher so dem ich bin gab am bahnhof
und ich habe einen stein in eisenstadt
und dann komme ich zum bahnhof und ich
bin in speyer lp ich kann dich
inspirieren
ich kann die keime töten erstmal jetzt
den cool cool cool cool cool der hat
mich davor geteilte der haut ihn sehr
gerne aus ich weiß wunderbar da die
schultern
regeneration mir auch die reisen städten
machen ich gehe mal gut zu sparen
die magische frage ist jetzt wer ist wie
viele ich töte gerade ist ein adventure
alter also eine art immer noch gut
herzen 7 herzen noch mit dem stadt
angezeigt lustigerweise und das kann
zeit ne was will man machen ja okay gut
manche haben all die skills ich
definitiv nicht aber gut dafür daumen
dafür bin ich mutter nicht an deinen
deine deine flop müssen wie heißt du
einmal schipplock mit zuckerpaste sind
nicht helfen loxstedt
tlz die catwalk hier ist eine tochter
hat ios heavy am kippen
es ist erst morgen und jetzt schon
profis immer noch werde weil ich wer am
bahnhof ich bin ich den showdown mit den
neuen crafter ist an sich schon ist
schon kleinod so also des herrn horst
roos ganz feines am center for ruin ab
jetzt leute ich kann mich ich kann mich
umbenennen solchen kräften in hd wenn
ich den neuen crafter lp weiß party
schon gibt könnt ihr über einen chat
wenn das bist du nicht mehr als stream
oder scheiße man den stadtteil
ich habe gerade das sinnvoll auf twitter
ja bei mir mit hast du denn wo ist denn
ich bin am bahnhof anlassen ich kenne
ich bin ja bei den loks dahinten ich hab
mir grad eingeholte mit eisen chefs
profi sich kurz mal an alter debt for
king equipment ich würde auch gern ein
bisschen entscheiden hier so jetzt hat
der mieter der den crafter ich habe ein
anrecht hat vor mir in den ins nico pvp
er kann aber nicht so gut pvp deswegen
weil ich vor uns verbindet keine ahnung
das macht die leute gerne mal in der
gleichen kraft ab er hat nicht mal
direkt in der zwischenzeit einfach
unglaublich eingebaut einfach die fakten
nicht kann mir nicht helfen gehört
gefragt der hits alter der hit von dem
ok aber ich glaube du bist immer noch an
disney co pvp hd dran
er ist ja okay jetzt räche ich dich du
bist bei mir dann können wir jetzt ja
ich bin ja ich bin da bist du ja ja die
anderen der kripo alter schwede
da fragt man sicherlich noch verloren
ist irgendwas cooles nicht streng kinder
sind gut
leider nicht selber nur noch eine stelle
an und natürlich das absolute gangster
team jetzt fest ihr zu zweit durch die
gegend ist immer gangster sind immer
gangs energy power ja eben auch wenn
mobbing nur pvp und weißbrot namens
changer merkt man sofort
dieser name ist ainedter was der was ist
los mit den leuten leute da weißt du
dann vertraut euch mojang und er macht
ihr so was
von dem mobilen mit einem plus bester
mobiler ich laufe hier rüber auf die
gefahr dass sie stecken bleibe
accra martin weissbrodt ist tot aber
marie super den börsen selfmade keiner
ist ok weiter dann nicht immer auf
mobbing
du hast dich auf dem kleinen warteraum
mysteriöse art und weise viel zu dunkel
die arena ich nicht nicht nicht brennt
brennt mich endlich einmal hat mich
einmal die kopfnote mich ok power hilfe
okay wir machen gar kein typ tu die baby
noodles ok danke gut und jetzt jetzt
direkt weiter direkt weiter mit
handschlag es mit hand schlagen als von
hand schlagen ja los gehts ja direkt war
okay was wir kurzen tranken alles klar
die nummern leben na ja ich weiss ich
sag ja ich sagen okay das ist
der sitz nicht schlecht manchmal sogar
sogar mainz mainz kastel viele dieser
liste war ordentlich leute der doppels
und einer beschreibung check-in gerne
mal ab falls sie noch nicht kennt wir
sehen uns bei der nächsten folge wieder
das den daumen nach oben da wirklich
gefallen hat